my name is Canadians and PhD student
here at Stanford and I'm going to talk
about bullet proofs which are short
proofs for confidential transaction and
a lot more actually and this is joint
work with Jonathan bulu from the
University College London my adviser Dan
bidet and Andrew Peter and Gregg or
Andrew and Peter from block stream in
Gregg Maxwell so um this is a talk about
so if you've you might have seen as this
is kind of a depiction of what a Bitcoin
transaction looks like but the same
thing applies to other cryptocurrencies
very similarly and and the important
thing to note is that there is some sort
of inputs on the Left that come into the
transaction and some up sort of outputs
that go out of the transaction and it is
important that the inputs are greater or
equal to the outputs or the outputs are
less then the inputs and actually the
difference between the outputs and
inputs is exactly the fee that is sort
of paid to the miners for verifying the
transactions this is all you need to
understand about Bitcoin and blockchain
you don't there's just some generic a
transaction format and so when is a
Bitcoin transaction valid well there's
three criterion really one of them is
that the signature is correct so that
there's some person you know who owns
the inputs authorizes that the
transactions being spend the second one
is that the inputs are unspent so you
cannot spend money twice and then the
third one is the one that we're going to
care most about today which is that the
sum of the inputs is equal to the sum of
the outputs plasti fees so one problem
with Bitcoin transactions and and many
other cryptocurrency transaction is that
they're not confidential or they don't
have any privacy so they're neither what
we call confidential anonymous and by
confidentiality I mean that the amounts
are hidden and by anonymity I mean that
you can see who's paying whom and you
can see these addresses you know they
they hide like it doesn't say that who's
paying whom and in terms of real world
identities but it actually turns out
that it's quite easy to figure out
which address and then you can clearly
see how much money is being transferred
it's publicly available on the
blockchain and you can see who is paying
who so why is this a problem well this
has many epic implications for
businesses especially the the
transaction amounts being available in
the clear
and for example it means that if you
receive your salary in Bitcoin or some
other similar cryptocurrency it is that
your salary will be public and everybody
can just look up what your salary is and
also if your business and you're buying
some sort of tools from your supplier
say you know Ford buys tires from from
mr. law or whatever and then they can
see everybody can publicly see how much
is being paid for these goods and these
are important business secrets that
business would want to hide so this
really makes block chains in some ways
at least less usable for for businesses
so to combat this there's this idea
above confidential transactions which
Maxwell came up in 2016 which and the
idea is that instead of sending the
amounts in the clear we encrypt them or
more correctly we use a cryptographic
commitment which is kind of like saying
we put the amounts in an envelope a
cryptographic commitment is something
that does not reveal the value but after
the fact I can only open it to be the
value that I originally committed to so
just like an envelope and and then so
concretely we would use these Pettersen
commitments which are basically block
based so the problem now obviously if no
one or if it's publicly not visible what
the amounts are how can we check that
the transaction is valid and especially
how can we check that third constraint
that the sum of inputs is greater equal
to the sum of outputs and it actually
turns out that there's a second thing
that we need to check even if we have
this you know this equality check or
this this greater equal check from the
inputs and outputs and it turns out that
we also need to check that both of the
outputs are positive right because
otherwise if I have five Bitcoin going
in and I have -2 and 7 Bitcoin going out
then the the first check goes through
but the second check obviously
doesn't go through and I've now created
seven I have a seven Bitcoin output
which is a big problem and the second
test the the positive outputs is
actually the more difficult one and that
the one that we'll focus on today the
other one is simpler because there's
this additive homomorphic property of
the commitment scheme so these
confidential transactions were proposed
in 2016 as I said and it is kind of the
the structure is similar to a Bitcoin
transaction the transaction graph so
who's paying whom is still publicly
available so we do not hide that there's
other cryptocurrencies like Z cash or
more narrow that that use that have
tools kind of for hiding the transaction
graph but the question is how do we
achieve this public verify ability of
transaction validity well luckily
there's this tool called zero knowledge
proof of knowledge so in a zero
knowledge proof of knowledge you have
approver and a verifier and the proof of
Peggy wants to convince the verify of
Victor that this commitment that she has
is actually a commitment to a positive
number and traditionally this works
through some sort of challenge response
protocol where Victor gets to ask
questions to Peggy and Peggy can only
answer these questions if the statement
that she's trying to prove is true if
not then she will be unable or with high
probability she will be unable to answer
these questions but the answers to the
questions her responses do not reveal
any information about the the the kind
of secret information that she's using
to prove the statement so it doesn't
reveal the X or the R in this case and
after this protocol is run and this can
be a multiple round protocol victor will
be convinced that Peggy knows this value
X and that it X is positive but he has
still no idea what exactly the value
axis and this is called concretely what
we're trying to prove here would be
called a range proof so you can prove
that X isn't a number between say zero
and two to the 52 and it turns out that
we can make this whole thing even non
interactive and publicly verifiable so
this is kind of
referenced ring and and Peggy can just
write down a proof and then after the
fact Victor or someone else can can
check the proof and put it and and be
convinced that X is in fact positive and
so for example this is a proof that you
could put on the blockchain attached to
your transaction and everybody is then
convinced that your transaction is in
fact valid so how could we make such a
proof well at a very high level what
does it mean for a number to be in some
range so between 0 and 2 to the say 64
bits well what it means is that I can
write it down using 64 bits right that a
number between 0 & 2 to the 64 I can
write down using 64 bits so one idea is
that Peggy will create a commitment for
each of the bits and then send over
these you know n commitments if we're
trying to prove to be that that X is
between 0 & 2 to the 64 minus 1 actually
and to prove and the proof says that
each of the committed values these
little committed values is in fact a
commitment to either 0 1 and that the
the big commitment so the whole number
is the the combination of these bit
commitments so the problem with this
range proof and this is what we could
call a linear range proof and you can
base it on these Sigma protocols and use
the Fiocchi mere heuristic to make it
non interactive is that they're fairly
large so they're four kilobytes even
with some recent optimizations for a 64
bit range proof and if I try to increase
the bit the number of bits and my range
then the proof will grow linearly right
because I had to send over even just one
commitment perb for it in my range so
the nice thing is they don't have a
trusted set them and I'll talk about
that in in a second but four kilobytes
for you know this would mean a 4
kilobyte proof being attached to every
transaction that is not really practical
today with what block chains can handle
today
so there are shorter proofs and and one
of the
and they're called these pre-processing
snarks and what they do is there's kind
of a trusted set up so in the beginning
there's some sort of some party that
creates these queries encrypts them
sends them to the proven gives the
verifier some advice string that will
help it to to check the answers to these
queries and you can actually create
really really short proofs and these
proofs are you know a couple like two
hundred by it's irrespective of the
complexity of the statement that you're
trying to prove so no matter whether
it's a short-range proof a long-range
proof or an even more complex statement
the size of the proof is only a couple
hundred bytes the problem with this is
that and verification is also fast which
is nice the problem with this is that
say the person who does the setup is
actually malicious and for example
colludes with the prove or tries to
create a proof by himself then he can
suddenly he can create fake proofs so he
convinced you of statements that aren't
true so he could commit to a negative
number and prove to you that it is a
positive number and the verify would be
fooled so why is this why is this a
problem why are these trusted setups a
problem especially in cryptocurrencies
well the problem is that what does it
mean to create a fake proof well if the
subvert approver of the setup is
subverted then this is a this is
undetectable there's no way to really
test for it and B then you can create
these transactions which have say
negative amounts of the in them and what
that really means is that I can create
money out of thin air it is inflation
and it is even undetectable inflation
because now all the amounts are being
hidden right it's not like an in Bitcoin
where all the amounts are public and you
can check how much total money there is
if the trusted setup is being subverted
then no one knows how much money there
is and there's really you know it's it's
undetectable inflation and then attack
it could really extract a lot of money
from the system so it's a it's a
very bad situation and the problem is
that even if you don't have a separate
set up even the fear of this
undetectable the inflation is dangerous
so for example Z cash Eustace uses these
Snorks and there's people going around
saying or you know they that's saying
you know it's not secure this appear
that the setup is subverted which you
know they did a very good job at trying
to prevent that but like there's really
nothing more that you can say there's no
proof that you can give to people to say
no the setup was done correctly and and
and this fear can lower for example the
price of the cryptocurrency and the
value of it and and the willingness of
people to use it so the way to alleviate
this is usually through this kind of
distributed setup and so-called
multi-party computation and this is
difficult but Zee cash actually did that
and and and it's doing that for but it's
you know this you can read up on it and
Z cash ceremony there is a great podcast
on it I think I planted money or
something and it's yeah they had to do a
lot of work to do this and it's kind of
annoying and you still don't solve all
the problems and also every time you add
some new functionality it means that you
have a new set up right every time you
change even the slightest thing you
would have to redo the setup so they
have to actually redo the setup right
now so that again is a problem so for
example there's Hart which is you know
smart it's kind of a smart contract
confidential smart contract a private
smart contract a proposal for that a
paper and what they had is that there's
a different trusted set up for every
single smart contract and that clearly
doesn't seem feasible so with that in
mind we were looking for you know other
approved systems that could help that
did not have this trusted set up but
still could be used for these range
proofs so we this is paper by by
Jonathan brutal and and the group at
University College London which are
these lock size proofs for arithmetic
circuit so this is a proof protocol
again for arithmetic circuit which means
for kind of
Vittoria computation and the nice thing
is that the proves are only logarithmic
in the size of the computation so as in
Tata CLE this seemed great and it only
realized it also doesn't have a tress it
said up and only relies on the discrete
log assumption the problem was that in
practice if you actually wanted to do
arrange proof you would have to do a
proof that you know this value you would
have to implement the commitment
function which is a multi exponentiation
within the circuit and things get rather
expensive and in practice it would not
have been much better than than the
linear protocol that was out there
especially in size and probably a lot
worse in terms of proving in
verification time but we took we looked
at their protocol and changed it and
improved it such that it would work
better for these range proves and also
it works better in general and and this
is how we came up with bulletproof which
allows you now to do proves uncommitted
values and what that means is that I can
do a proof on something that is within
the commitment I don't have to implement
the commitment function or the opening
function of the commitment within the
arithmetic circuit so and also we reduce
the proof size by a factor of three
which means that now you only have to
give to log 2 of n elements for a range
proof and these improvements also
transfer over to arbitrary arithmetic
circuits which means when I say
arithmetic circuits I mean that I can
prove to you that I know some secret
inputs to a circuit or a function such
that the function evaluates to say 1 ok
and I don't have to give you what these
values are but I can convince you that I
know these secret values so you can
implement more complex functionalities
with this so let's see what this kind of
this improvement - like - log n elements
what does this mean in practice well for
a single range proof this means that our
proofs are 670
bytes versus the previous range proof
which was four kilobytes and snarks are
you know 188 bytes so they clearly
knocked the ball out of the park but
they are they have the problem with the
chess etcetera the nice thing is that
you know a transaction as I just picked
the picked it earlier usually has
multiple outputs so say it has two
outputs and I want to prove to you that
both of these outputs are positive which
is the usual situation well it turns out
because we have this logarithmic scaling
this we can just create one bullet-proof
for both of these outputs and what that
means is that suddenly now both of these
proofs together are just 736 bytes so we
just added 64 bytes to double the number
of proofs that we're doing whereas the
previous proof would scale linearly so
it would be eight kilobytes and this
goes on you know if I have ten proves
it's 928 by its vs. almost 40,000 bytes
so the more outputs or the the larger
the statement is that you're trying to
prove the larger the savings are that
your that that bullet proves has versus
these traditional pros so when would we
ask ourselves well when would what these
transactions ever have that many outputs
right like you know you might send some
Bitcoin to your whole family for
Christmas but usually right like you
only have two outputs so but there's
multiple people at the same time that
are trying to do a transaction trying to
create a boat so we looked at the
situation where there's multiple provers
each of them have a commitment right
each of them want to send some money and
they want to create a single proof
without revealing the secrets to each
other and that all of the their
commitments commit to say positive
numbers or they want to prove something
about these commitments but concretely
we cared about range proofs and well how
can they create one proof well well
trivial solutions obviously they can
concatenate their proofs but
we would want something that is
something where the proof is small so
generic way to do this is a multi-party
computation but it turns out that we can
create other the the prover is is
extremely structured so we can create
this custom multi-party computation
which allows these provers to Anna kind
of create one proof together instead of
having multiple proofs and this works
whenever kind of each of them wants to
prove a separate statement and then the
the overall statement statement is just
a conjunction of all of their statements
so it's you know prove of one wants to
say my values in some range and then
prove or two wants to say my values and
another range and prove with me once we
prove something completely different but
it's just an end between these three
things so the nice thing is that we can
do this in a logarithmic number of
rounds so there has to be some
communication and with the logarithmic
amount of computation unification or
there's a different protocol which just
has three rounds but has linear
communication so more communication so
this is a trade of kind of that we
provide and there's you know multiple
levels in between that and so the nice
thing is that this allows us there is
already this protocol for which is
called I think I have it on the next
slide what it's called but there's this
protocol for combining transactions with
multiple users can combine transactions
and the traditional reason why this was
used is because people wanted to hide
who they're sending money to right so
you get some added anonymity from that
but now with confidential transactions
and with bulletproof it actually makes
the the average size or it makes the
size of the proof and by that the
transaction fees which scale linearly in
the size of the transaction it makes it
cheaper so there's even economic
incentives to combine your transactions
into one transaction that is smaller
so what are the kind of you know what
are the results of this how can can
bulletproof help for confidential
transaction or this this is also this
new blockchain format called mimimum
boom well as I said it's 670 bytes
instead of 4 kilobytes per range proof
and a 64-bit range but again then this
aggregation really helps to make this
this gap a lot bigger so for 16 range
proves it's 930 bytes versus 61
kilobytes and doubling at the doubling
the precision would only add 64 bytes
right again this is just this
logarithmic scaling and concretely if
kind of the structure of transaction
didn't change which we would assume it
would because there's new incentives
even then if you just applied the old
confidential transactions to Bitcoin you
UTX oset would be 160 gigabytes and now
with bulletproof said it would be 17
gigabytes and this is the protocol that
I was talking about it was called coin
join that was the name I couldn't think
of so it has this kind of built-in
simple conjoint protocol for combining
transactions into a single one and we
also looked at whether so the the
protocol is susceptible to two kind of
quantum attacks and and we looked at
things that which is a it's susceptible
to attacks by a quantum computer and we
looked at things that perhaps you know
where quantum computer could only break
the hiding property of the the proofs of
the zero knowledge property of the proof
but not the actual so-called soundness
and the problem is this so the idea is
that an attacker could reveal or see how
much money everybody is spending so
break the privacy but not print your
money it turns out that because we using
compression so it turns out because we
want our proofs to be actually smaller
than the statement that we're proving
this is it's impossible to to get this
unconditional soundness
so as I said you know bulletproof also
works for these arbitrary statements so
for example you could use it on Z cash
and the proof size would be 1.7
kilobytes but actually Z cash is
improving kind of their circuit and that
would help bulletproof a lot so it would
be 1.3 kilobytes there's a reason why Z
cash can probably not switch to bullet
proof which is that the verification
time the proof size scales logarithmic
in the size of the proof but the
verification time is still linear so the
more complex if I'm trying to prove to
you a statement that is twice as complex
verifying it will take roughly twice as
long and so this is an overview over
kind of different proof systems and the
short takeaway from this is that there's
multiple you know the state space is
really developing there's multiple
different proof systems out there each
of them has different benefits and it
really depends on the application which
one is the best one to use so you know
snarks are extremely efficient in terms
of verifier time and and proof size but
they have this trusted set up and you
know the bullet proofs are short but the
verifier takes linear time so this
doesn't work for if you know the
statement you're trying to prove is too
complex so you know if you have to
really think about your application when
you it's there's no clear winner out
there so you have to do some thinking
and it's really application specific of
what the best tool is and I just want to
touch on like one or maybe two other
things where we're bulletproof scan also
help so we had this protocol in that we
developed in 2015 which allowed Bitcoin
exchanges to prove that they're solvent
so that they have enough money for
paying out all their customers without
revealing any information so without
revealing how much money they have in
total or what their Bitcoin addresses
are or any of these information so it's
kind of a zero knowledge proof for
solvency and with bullet proof this
would dramatically reduce the
to prove from like 18 gigabytes to a
couple of megabytes another application
outside the realm of blockchains is
something called a verifiable shuffle so
this is used in so-called mixed Nets
where each sender you know wants to
there's a couple senders each of them
has an email and there's a receivers and
you want to somehow have this
interactive protocol which hides which
message is going to whom and one core
component of this is you need to produce
these zero knowledge proves that the
inputs and outputs or that you know n
encrypted inputs and n encrypted outputs
are the same and it turns out that you
know with bulletproof sits it's the
first logarithmic size verifiable
shuffle without a trusted setup so this
is there's proving that the inputs and
outputs are the same is called a
verifiable shuffle right I shot for the
values and I can prove to you that I did
it correctly and with both groups we can
do this very efficiently and so we also
implemented this or let's say Andrew and
Peter did an amazing job at implementing
this into the Bitcoin cryptographic
library with you know the the prover is
constant time so there's no timing
attacks there and the verifier is
extremely fast and I know that there's
multiple other implementations and
progress are already out there and one
of the main things that we did when when
implementing is kind of boiling down
this very complex verification protocol
to there's one simple big multi
exponentiation which is just as this
check that you see here on the right so
if i want to check a proof i just kind
of have to do this base it almost boils
down and hiding some details here to
this one check so the reason why this is
interesting is because multi
exponentiation is to some degree it's
it's sublinear so it scales with n over
log n and this actually gives us some
benefits and it turns out that for for
small circuits verifying so for example
for range proofs verifying a
bullet-proof is even faster than
verifying a snark the other thing that
there's more
to exponentiation gives us is that say I
have to bulletproof okay and then I have
these two big multi exponent stations
that I need to verify where only the
exponents are different or most of the
generators kind of the things at the
bottom and are the same but the
exponents are different well it turns
out that there is this batch
verification technique that was
originally designed for signatures and
but it also applies here where you can
kind of you just combine these equations
by raising the first one two random
scalar alpha and then adding them
together and what this means is that I
need to do a couple more scalar
operations but I still only need to do
the same number of exponentiations and
if you've ever implemented cryptography
it turns out that these these
exponentiations are a lot more expensive
than the scalar operations so in effect
what this does is that verifying the
first proof is this is I think for a
64-bit range proof is 6.2 milliseconds
and verifying the second one is only 550
microseconds so a factor of ten times
less and you know if you for example a
minor and want to verify a whole block
of transactions your your amortized cost
is really closer to the 550 microseconds
so yeah thank you very much the the
website for where you can find the paper
and links to the implementations is
crypto at stanford.edu backslash
bulletproof thank you very much
[Applause]
well yeah so Manero which is I think the
10th largest cryptocurrency actually
they announced that they will implement
this because they all have you know
they've been struggling with their
transaction sizes because they use the
traditional confidential transactions
and so they will actually implement this
and I think you know their goal is by
the end of the year that bullet proofs
will secure this multi-billion dollar
cryptocurrency which is you know it's
it's in some ways it's it's very cool in
other ways it's pretty insane you know
that like research that is no it's a
it's it's a me cool that yeah like this
the know how fast you know in this space
I think research is getting deployed
into practice I mean I think you said at
some point like usually it takes 7 or 17
years or something for crypto to be
deployed and yes of course there's no
patent the library is open source you
can use it I think it's yeah very
probably I don't know what the license
is but something permissive for
businesses and so yeah thank you
[Applause]